these seven Admirals are the world
government's greatest military power
considered to be some of the strongest
fighters in the entire series and today
we will explain and rank all of them
starting with aokiji the blue pheasant
kuzan is the first Admiral we were
introduced to in the anime after the
straw hat crew encountered him during
the long-ring long land Arc there he
easily outclassed the whole crew and
made Luffy realize just how powerful the
animals really are although kuzan tries
to follow the world government orders he
occasionally disreguids them which was
best shown in alhara when he lets young
Robin Escape he was also shocked by
sakazuki's decision to blow up a ship
full of civilians which he thought was
completely unnecessary kuzan ate the
hiah no me a lokia type devil fruit that
allows him to create control and
transform his body into ice since ice is
a solid element kuzan can be hit easily
even with the attacks not being fused
with hockey however these attacks cannot
harm him in any way instead his body
would just shatter apart when struck
only to effortlessly be formed seconds
later kuzan is also able to form
constructs out of ice for example in
combat you can create Weaponry primarily
forming swords and Spears but he can
also make more advanced things like a
giant pheasant to send flying at enemies
an interesting thing about kusan is that
he's one of the few devil fruit users
who can bypass the weakness of falling
into the sea he can achieve this by
freezing the sea before you can sink
below the surface not only does this
keep him from drowning but it also lets
him prevent enemies from escaping by sea
by freezing their ships in place or
rendering the sea a solid Battleground
for entire armies to fight on during the
summit war kuzan's power was well
exemplified with him engaging Whitebeard
the strongest man in the world head to
head in holding his own he also battled
zozu one of the whitebeard's most
formidable men and defeated him with
relative ease completely incapacitating
him for the rest of the war ultimately
kuzano emerged from the war almost
entirely unscathed with nothing but a
small bruise which when you think about
the scale of this war it's pretty
impressive after the Marine fordward he
was nominated for the position of Fleet
Admiral but lost it in combat against
takaini after akanye was appointed
aokiji resigned from his position
refusing to serve under a kind due to
his cruelty following his departure from
the Marines he became part of the
Blackbeard Pirates one of the most
feared crews in the world based on all
of this aokiji should easily be in the a
tier ryokugyu the green bull ryokugu
attained his Admiral status off screen
during the two-year time skin killing
one of the two free Admiral spots left
by aokijianakaini during the latest
level ryokukyu and fujitora engaged in
battle with the flame member Sabo and a
few revolutionary Army commanders he
also effortlessly defeated king and
queen two All-Stars of the Beast pirates
with bounties of over 1 billion bellies
ryokukyu ate the morimorino me a lokia
type devil fruit that allows him to
create control and transform his body
into plants notably as plants are a
solid element He cannot turn intangible
however non-hockey attacks are still
harmless to him and he'll easily heal
from any damage the way he regenerates
is also pretty interesting as he
regenerates by sprouting out of the
ground and growing back into his normal
self when attacking the Beast Pirates he
turned his fingers into sharpened tree
branches and freely grew them to inhale
dozens of enemies over a large share you
with ease additionally his plants can
rapidly absorb any liquid they touch
which includes dehydrating leaving
creatures after impaling them leading
them as shriveled husks furthermore he
appears to be able to taste the liquid
he absorbs as shown when he impaled a
barrel of alcohol with a branch and
remarked on its flavor he can also
perform really unusual Feats with the
plants that he generates such as growing
a giant flower on his backing using it
to fly it has also been shown that
ordinary grass and flowers grow on any
surface he touches resulting in him
leaving behind a trail of plants
wherever he walks this was shown when
udon which is known to be a Barren in
desolate area was shown with Greenery
for the first time in many years it's
unknown if this is passively active or
something he does on purpose but it's
cool nonetheless although ryokuyu is
obviously a very strong fighter I don't
really think he's on the same level as
aokiji so I'll have to put him in beat
here the yellow monkey kizaru is the
only remaining Admiral from the previous
Trio without kiji leaving in a kainu
being promoted as with other Admirals
hisar's mere presence is enough to cause
mass panic and scare many weaker Pirates
this this was perfectly showcased on the
celebrity archipelago where most of the
supernovas fled upon seeing him while on
the island kizaru was able to overwhelm
four of said supernovas Hawkins uroge X
Drake and Oppo with no effort defeating
each of them in a single attack gizotto
also engaged in a one-on-one battle
against Silver's Rayleigh the former
right hand of the pirate king and one of
the strongest Swordsmen in the world
during their short battle while Rayleigh
looked very tired kizaru seemed calm
implying that if their fight continued
he would easily be able to defeat him
during the summit War he once again
showcased his strength by battling
several of whitebeard's division
commanders on equal footing and later
Whitebeard himself Lulu was able to
seriously injured without a doubt his
greatest strength lies in his devil
fruit the Pika pikanomi which allows him
to turn his body into light with it he
can move at light speed allowing him to
maneuver around the battlefield without
his enemies being able to keep up unless
they have sufficiently developed
observation hockey gizotto also uses his
light speed to repeatedly smash the
Subscribe button alright that's just
it's a stupid joke but you should
seriously press it if you like the
content thanks thanks anyway you can
also kind of teleport himself using the
devil fruit transforming his body into
light and appearing in another location
his physical attacks can be strengthened
as well by moving his leg at the speed
of light the Admiral's kicks can be
given massive weight and momentum
greatly increasing their power and
allowing kizado to deal tremendous
damage to opponents with individual
blows now kizado is a very tricky
Admiral to ring as he's always very
confident and thinks he can easily
defeat anyone for now I'll have to put
him in the AIDS here but he definitely
has the potential to be an S tier in the
future if he proves himself black arm
Zephyr Zephyr also known as Z was a
former Marine Admiral and the
commander-in-chief of the neo-marines he
served as the main antagonist of one
Piece Film Z where he and his forces
clashed with the straw hat Pirates as
they were caught in the midst of his
grand plan to destroy the new world
after he resigned from the millions he
was requested to stay in the military as
an instructor and he trained many
powerful Cadets who had become the
high-ranking officers of their
generation including kizaru aokiji and
akaini even after he completely
abandoned the world government many of
his former students showed genuine
remorse having to fight their instructor
indicating that he was an excellent and
charismatic teacher alongside GARP
sangoku and suru Z was one of the most
powerful Marines of his generation
another interesting thing about him is
that he's the only no Marine Admiral
that doesn't possess the devil food
Powers despite his old age Zephyr had
tremendous physical prowess he was
easily able to counter Luffy Zoro and
Sanji despite fighting them inside of a
small cabin with none of the three
strongest straw hats able to land her
Direct Hit since he didn't eat a devil
fruit he mostly relied on his
hand-to-hand combat skills using his
physical strength and hockey to fight he
could Clash evenly against Luffy while
in his Gear 2 form and keep up with
kizaru for some time he was aware of his
age though and after his final battle
against Luffy he admitted that he had
grown old and weak since ephra is
considered non-canon and there isn't
much information about his Feats as an
admiral I'll unfortunately have to put
him in seat here fujitora the Wisteria
tiger same as green bull fujitora
attained his rank off-screen during the
time skip his Justice motto as a marine
is Humane just and his primary goal is
to protect as many people as possible he
tries to never put innocent civilians In
Harm's Way during conflicts and avoids
causing collateral damage with his
attacks overall he's a pretty good guy
he's also really strong as well as he
was able to fight Sabo to more or less
of a standstill emerging from a battle
without a scratch it was also evident
that he didn't go all out in this battle
and merely stalled for time which means
that his actual power is way higher
another one of fujitora's Feats is
defeating Jax kaido's top commander in a
naval battle despite being blind due to
his other acute senses and observation
hockey fujitora can handle himself
perfectly well in combat even against
very powerful enemies notably he has
excellent hearing having heard nami's
lightning from kilometers away when
neither doflamingo nor La next to him
did he also stated that he's able to
sense the movement of clouds which
doesn't seem very useful but it's cool I
guess fujitana ate the Sushi Zushi Nomi
a paramisia type devil fruit that allows
him to manipulate gravitational forces
fujitora can drastically increase the
gravity around others keep them on the
ground and making it difficult for them
to move you can also further increase
the gravity and press down opponents
under immense pressure even going as far
as to create large craters deep into the
ground moreover the Admiral can also use
these Powers defensively by making
fields of reverse gravity to repel
attacks you can also use gravity to pull
objects directly towards himself which
fujitotah has used multiple times to
summon meteorites to strike his
opponents despite his incredibly
powerful devil fruit abilities ishel is
also a master swordsman which he showed
when he easily deflected Soto's attack
and sent him underground although he saw
fujitotify several times it was never
again seriously strong opponents
therefore for now I'll have to put him
in the B tier with green bull akinu the
red dog akinu is the current Fleet
admiral of the Rings and is believed by
fans to be the strongest current Admiral
in the story sakazuki has command over
the entire Marine organization from
ordering all soldiers and officers as he
sees fit to issuing a buster call on any
Island he deems to be a threat his only
superiors are the world government's
commander-in-chief Kong and the five
Elders Akino is an Adam believer in
absolute Justice and he believes that
all evil should be eradicated even if it
requires sacrificing innocent Minds in
the process he is incredibly rigid and
absolute in his beliefs showing little
compassion for anyone or anything and is
ruthlessly willing to do whatever it
takes to serve his own goals no matter
the cost because of this akinu is by far
the most ruthless out of the three
pre-time skip Admirals during the Buster
call attack on Ohara sakazuki's beliefs
led him to go as far as destroying a
refugee ship full of innocent people and
Marines simply because of the slight
possibility that a scholar could be
hiding on board sakazuki's logic was
that if even one of the scholars of
Ohara had escaped the entire Mission
would have been a failure during the
summit War sakazuki's fighting prowess
was well established against Whitebeard
whom the Admiral matched up to in a
head-to-head confrontation while
Whitebeard managed to gain the upper
hand and deliver a serious blow to
Akainu the Admiral managed to melt off
half of whitebeard's face in the
exchange further during the war sakazuki
proved himself firmly Superior to Ace
effortlessly overpowering him in a clash
and killing him afterwards ultimate
currently sakazuki proved to be
unstoppable and not even the combined
efforts of jinbei Marco and Vista could
do anything more than slowing down it
was only when Shanks arrived and
personally engaged to kainu that he
finally stopped fighting we didn't see
much of a kainu post time skip but it is
believed that he got even more powerful
and will probably be one of the final
obstacles on Luffy's Journey after he
managed to defeat aokiji and build some
serious damage to White Beard I believe
that Akainu is the first Admiral that
deserves to be placed in the S tier
sengoku the Buddha sengoku was the fleet
admiral of the Marines during the first
half of the series he was one of the
major figures in the world along with
Whitebeard cheeky and GARP during the
times when Goldie Roger was still alive
sometime during the time skip he became
a general inspector and his position was
taken by akinu although not much is
known about sengoku's past we know that
he joined the Marines at the age of 23
and eventually rose up through the Rings
achieving Admiral status he was also
powerful enough to stop and capture the
Legendary Pirate Golden Lion Shiki in a
battle that destroyed half the Marine
for him during the summit War he mainly
stayed on the sidelines and was
responsible for commanding the Marine
forces he ultimately did a pretty good
job and with the kainu's help he managed
to turn one of whitebeard's allies
against him sengoku ate the hitohito
Nomi model daibutsu a mythical Zone type
devil fruit that allows him to transform
into a large Golden Buddha boosting his
powers and overall strength massively
this form also allows him to launch
golden shock Waves by striking his hands
forward and was strong enough to injure
even the Blackbeard Pirates when sengoku
first used his fruits powers in an
attempt to execute both Luffy and Ace
nearby Marines noted that they had never
seen him use it before suggesting that
he rarely transforms okay so where
should sengoku be in the rankings well
we need to take into account that he's
very old and before marineford he
probably didn't fight anyone for a long
time honestly I don't think he could
take on any of the younger animals in
his current state and therefore I'll
have to place him in the sea tier click
on this video where we explained 52
secrets about one piece that you
definitely didn't know